امام عدسات الكاميرات رصاصه اسرائيليه
تغتال الزميل شيرين ابو عقله اراد
الاحتلال من خلالها اغتيال الصوره وقتل
الحقيقه لكن هذه الجريمه اعادت احياء
عشرات الملفات
لصحفيين قتلوا على ارض فلسطين بقيت
اسمائهم ولحظات اغتيالهم محفوره في
الاذهان رغم ان قضاياهم ما تزال تبحث عن
عداله مغيبه لاحظت ان هناك مجموعه من
الصحفيين كانوا يسيرون في الشارع
كان في هذا الشارع جدران ومنازل ايضا وكان
ذلك بمثابه تقييد لمسار الرصاص عندما بدا
اطلاق النار
وكونت الطلقه صدمه تلاها انفجار الطلقه
كان هناك فارق زمني من هذا الفارق الزمني
تمكنت من حساب وتقدير مدى بعد مطلق النار
وفقا لحسابات فقد كان مطلق النار على بعد
ما بين
180 مترا الى 200 متر
واكتشفنا ايضا ان هناك مجموعه من جنود جيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي كانوا على بعد 200 متر
من ذلك التقاطع حيث كانت الصحفيه والمصور
لذا فان بصمه الصوت تتطابق مع المسافه
وتلك الرصاصات كانت تتجه نحو الصحفيه
وعليه اعتقد جازما ان ذلك يدعم حقيقه
مفادها ان اطلاق النار جاء من جنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي
فهل كانوا يستهدفون الصحفيين كانوا
بالتاكيد يصوبون باتجاه الصحفيين ان
الطلقه التي اصاب شيرين لم تكن نيرانا
عشوائيا رغما ان تلك الطلقات كانت متفاوته
ولكنها كانت متعمده وكان هناك عدد من
الطلقات التي اصابت الشجره بالقرب من
المكان الذي كان تقف فيه لم تكن نيرانا
عشوائيا من ابرز القضايا التي
هي قضيه قتل الصحفي البريطاني جيمس ميلر
عام 2003 برصاص جندي اسرائيلي في مدينه
رفح جنوب قطاع غزه هناك وثيقه نشرتها
السلطات الاسرائيليه تحجب جميع اسماء
الافراد المعنيين ولكن كان هناك اسم واحد
لم يتم اخفاؤه لكنه كان ملازما في قوات
الدفاع الاسرائيلي اعتقد انه كان بالخطا
لانه تم اخفاء اسمه تم شربه من التقرير
باكمله لكنه ظهر في سطر واحد لذلك نحن
نعرف من هو الضابط
بعد
كشره اليه وال
ضغط كشفت مراسلات اطلعنا عليها عن عرض
تسويه قدمته وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه عبر
السفاره البريطانيه في تل ابيب في ديسمبر
كانون الاول عام 2005 لاغلاق الملف
عام 2008 اعلن عن تسويه دفعت اسرائيل
بموجبها تعويضا ماليا بقيمه مليون
وسبعمائه وخمسين الف جنيه استرليني لعائله
جيمس ميلر مقابل اغلاق ملف محاكمه اي
عسكري اسرائيلي في القضيه ليس لدي شك بان
ضغط من الحكومه البريطانيه اثر بشكل كبير
على استجابه السلطات الاسرائيليه
بينما حصلت عائله الصحفي البريطانيه على
تعويض مالي برعايه الحكومه البريطانيه
تكدست قضايا صحفيين فلسطينيين محليين دون
عداله او محاوله للتعويض واحده من ابرزها
قضيه الصحفي الفلسطيني فضل شناعه مصور
وكاله رويترز البريطانيه للانباء في غزه
عام 2008 استهدفته قذيفه دبابه اسرائيليه
بشكل مباشر اثناء قيامه بعمله الصحفي وسط
قطاع غزه ارسلت طاقم بريطاني للتحقيق في
هذا المدى مع محاميين ولكن بدون اي نتيجه
طقم هذا ماستوفاج تحقيقات الاسرائيليين
رفضوا التعامل كليا كان معه جبه صغنون جيب
صحافه مكتوب عليه ايضا كان واقف على جنبه
بالضبط وهو هذا انا بتذكره تقريبا عشره
متر وكان امامي يعني انا شايفه تماما هيك
كنا نصور مباشره يعني بالاتجاه هذا كانت
الدباب الاسرائيلي والمسافه مش طويله يعني
عشان الدبابه نقول ما تشوفهاش لا الدبابه
كانت شيكانه تماما وكان الاشارات اللي انا
لابسينها كلنا لابسين وما شابه وفي خوذ
على روسنا عليها صحافه فجاه واحنا بنصور
صارت لقنا
[موسيقى]
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد مده وجيزه من
حادثه اغتيال فضل شناعه تبرئه واضحه
وكامله لطاقم الدبابه من تهمه الاغتيال
وقال محامي الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه لم يكن
واضحا للجنود ما اذا كان فضل يحمل كاميرا
او بندقيه ياسر مرتجى صحفي فلسطيني اخر
استشهد اثراء اصابته برصاصه قناص اسرائيلي
استهدفته اثناء تغطيته لمسيرات العوده عند
حدود قطاع غزه عام 2018
واتهم وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي انذاك
الصحفيه مرتجى بتسير طائره تصوير فوق جنود
الاحتلال
السيرن
بزروط الخماس الباير
توصلنا مع وكاله اسوشياده برست الامريكيه
للاستفسار عن المستجدات في قضيه نزيه
دروزه الذي كان مصورا للوكاله رغم عديد
المراسلات والمحاولات لم نتلقى اي رد منهم
يعني قاموا بزيارتنا بعد عمليه الاغتيال
وحضروا العزاء ولكن
الموضله انهم هم مواقع مبين برضه ولا
تابعوا اي ملف قانوني مع انها يعني هي
وكاله كبيره المفروض انها تاخذ على عاتقها
هذا الموضوع
تصادره عن المحكمه الاسرائيليه
في حي والمتعلقه بقضيه اغتيال الصحفي نزيه
دروزه ان اغلاق القضيه ناتج عن عدم مثول
الشهود امام المحكمه وهي ذريعه تكررت في
اكثر من قضيه بالنظر الى المنع المتعمد
للشهود من الوصول الى المحاكم من قبل
السلطات الاسرائيليه
وهذه المساحه فقط كنا نتخبى فيها هيك
نتخبى من الرصاص الاحتلال نزيه كان هون
وانا جنبه كتفي هون بكتفه يعني انا لم
استدعى ولم يطلب من الحضور مع اني انا كنت
ملاصق كتفي لكتفه
بالبحث في الوثائق الاسرائيليه نجد ان
اسرائيل قامت بتعديل سياساتها العسكريه مع
الانتفاضه الثانيه التي اندلعت عام 2000
وبناء عليها يعفى جنود وضباط الجيش من
المسائله في حاله ما تسميه النشاط العسكري
الاخطر من هذا كله ان مكتب
المدعي العام لم يحقق يوما في قضيه كما
ينبغي ان يكون التحقيق فهم يحققوا هل
اسرائيل في حاله حرب ام لا بالتالي المدار
العام العسكري هو يعمل على تغطيه هذه
الجريمه تشير الاحصاءات الى استشهاد خمسه
وخمسين صحفيا منذ العام 2000 برصاص
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في كل من مناطق الضفه
الغربيه وقطاع غزه فهي تعتبر انه ان من
تواجد في المسرح العمليات القتاليه وهذا
طبعا مصطلح فضفاض وواسع هم يعتبروا ان
الدوله معفيه من اي مسؤوليه على هذا الشخص
كونه انه تواجد في منطقه بات طبيعه قتاليه
بحسب مصادر خاصه فان مسؤولا اسرائيليا
كبيرا في مكتب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
السابق بني جانس اعترف لمسؤولين امريكيين
بان شيرين قتلت بنيران اطلقها الجنود
الاسرائيليون خطا لكن اسرائيل لم تعلن ولن
تعترف رسميا بذلك
شهر تسعه بعشرين تسعه بالضبط قدمنا الملف
لمحكمه الجنايه الدولي تعرضنا لمضايقات
ولكن بالنهايه سلمنا الملف نحن والابت
اجاءتنا الرساله ببعث لها بسلمك اياها
يعني بما معنى انه بدانا بالاجراءات ولكن
نحن نعتبر ذلك الكافر من الواضح من المدعي
العام للمحكمه الجمعيه الدوليه السيد كريم
كان منذ ان تولى هذا الامر قبل حوالي
عامين من الواضح انه يمارس ستسيس
والانتقائيه بصوره كامله في التعامل مع
الملف الفلسطيني هو يعني
في ملف اوكرانيا واقام الدنيا ورمي يقعدها
وخلال عام واحد كان بوتين قد اصدر ضده امر
اعتقال وفي الشان الفلسطيني لم يتحرك
مليمتر واحد حتى في مستوى الاتصال
والتواصل مع المحامين او مع الضحايا او
زياره المناطق او حتى اعطاء تصريح واحد
عما يدور في الاراضي المحتله لسوء يبدو ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي في مثل تلك المواقف يشعر
انه يمكنه الافلات من اي شيء
الشهيده والشاهده وعشرات من رفاق الدرب
الذين سبقوها اختبار للعداله في وجه
احتلال لا يكتفي بقتل الصحفيين في الميدان
بل يسعى الى واد الادله وقطع الطريق على
المحاكمات والافلات من العقاب في عالم
مزدوج المعايير
وما خفي اعظم